Je peux te poser une question ?
T'en voulais ?
Non ! Merci
Ah, tant mieux
Parce que j'ai faim ...
En fait je voulais te poser un question assez sérieuse
Vas-y
Est ce qu'on va mourir ?
Tu sais quoi, je vais t'en garder un peu quand même
Parce que, mine de rien
Le moisi ça donne un petit goût de ... reviensi
Ce serai dommage que tu goûtes pas !
Tu veux pas répondre à ma question plutôt ?
Bon !
Écoutes Bengi' ...
Bah !
Si tu prends le papillon, par exemple,
Au début c'est une larve ...
Puis après,
il devient tout dur comme un morceux de caillasse
pour finalement
devenir le papillon !
Un magnifique papillon !
Ça veux dire qu'on a de l'espoir !
Sauf qu'après, paf ! Il meurt !
Bah, il baise un peu avant ...
Mais après, paf ! Il meurt ! C'est con hein !
Tu veux pas répondre à ma questions avant de raconter tes conneries là ?
Si !
Mais avant on fait un jeu !
Quel jeu ?
On joue à celui qui compte le plus loin !
Aller je suis partis, hein !
Non mais je joue pas !
On fait un puzzle !
Aller !
Il y en a pas pour longtemps !
Non mais je veux pas jouer !
C'est con, j'ai déjà les coins !
Mais je m'en fou de ça !
Je veux juste savoir si on ...
Tu veux du cidre !
Du cidre ?
Bien sûr !
C'est du brute !
Ouai, bon bah clairement on va ...
À la plage !
Quoi ?
Aller !
On va piquer une tête, enfiles ton maillot !
Mais t'es complètement con,
On peux pas sortir, c'est trop ...
Comment ça on peut pas sortir ?
T'entends ça, philippe ?
Bengi' pense qu'on peut pas sortir !
Mais c'est toi,
tu m'as dis qu'il y avait une pluie d'acide, ou je sais pas quoi !
On pouvait pas foutre un pied devant l'autre !
Mais n'importe quoi !
C'est des "on dit" ça !
Tiens, regarde !
J'avoues, il y a un peu de cracha !
Bon aller, arrête !
Tu peux pas me répondre au moins une fois franchement ?
Ok
Je vais être franc !
C'est du lambris qu'on aurai dû mettre !
Toi t'as toujours voulus des peintures murales !
Stop !
STOP !
J'en peut plus !
J'en peux plus ! Tu le comprends pas ça, tu le vois pas ?!
J'en peut plus de ces quatres murs en bétons !
J'en peux plus, j'en peux plus des cafards !
C'est pas fait pour bouffer les cafard !
Et on les bouffes quand ?!
En entrée ?!
Au dessert ?!
Au petit dej' ?!
J'en peux plus de Philippe !
Que t'essaies de faire passer pour mon frère !
Tu crois que j'ai pas vu que c'était pas mon frère ?!
Et surtout ...
Et surtout, j'en peux plus de mensonges.
J'en peux plus des "ça va aller Bengi' !"
"T’inquiètes pas Bengi' !"
"Tu veux jouer Bengi' ?"
Non !
Je veux pas jouer !
Réponds moi au moins une fois franchement papa.
Est ce qu'on va mourir ?
Oui ou non ?
Ouai.
Ok !
Aller, on va à la plage !
Ouai !
ça va ?
Je crois que je me suis cassé la jambe !